[Music]
in shitty parenting news submitted by
Beal you don't have to understand out of
your body w because it goes boo oh yeah
if you don't know what it is how do you
yeah you read and go w [ __ ] you up is
that sometimes I read stuff in Spanish
to like without it being in Spanish so
bare parents issued their 18 year old
son a heartbreaking eviction notice
good Wow but it's a heartbreak why is it
oh because it's heartbreaking
is it did you cry deaf did you get sad I
did not cry what is the situation's
answer [ __ ] up from the parents I
forgot to give you a message when we're
at her show this one chick came up to us
and was like when's Isaac legal I
remember that [ __ ] she wanted to [ __ ]
his brains out huh well well she didn't
say that why don't you tell her right
now the eviction I'm like you better
watch out he kick guys are gonna fiction
cuz he might because Isaac might get
some [ __ ] wait who's Isaac hey but
they're not that different if she's a
college student she's probably like 19
or 18 and Isaac's like 12 so play a ball
that's pretty close that you're just
roll your pet oh [ __ ] out there stay
away seven more years you could diddle
the fiddle no now just threw me off but
god damn it let me he's gonna be but
she's 25 wait wouldn't she be 25 holy
when he's 18 why get their way oh I
don't know have you seen Isaac do today
come on man
he looks like he's a thank-you down
everybody that's like a chick who goes
to see Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone and she's like I want to [ __ ] that
kid wait a minute what happened what a
dream we lost you I like it the equally
as weird yeah as strange as that
gallop like an infant good I'm just I'm
[ __ ] dizzy yeah I don't know that
just like my head palms are sweaty I
mean I think that watching this Glenda
really yeah
like removing the fact that you the fact
things my son it just makes me wish if a
say makes me have this like physical
like reaction they're just like whoa I'm
just picturing my tiny little baby when
you was first born so that's way bigger
than that now do you think that's a trip
imagine how it's gonna be at his wedding
seven years from now I know it's [ __ ]
weird that's why I get Cambodian girl do
you look like the same age as Isaac we
just yeah but you don't know children is
okay I think I'm pretty sure you still
think tagged as a [ __ ] newborn okay
five more minutes on this on the move on
okay he wants a story the eviction story
yeah the sweet eviction story okay that
was just so weird all right let me focus
told I was gonna pass it on you did
don't do that again to me know Bart
actually said that yeah she didn't tell
me to pass it on she just told me to I'm
like I'll tell it if yeah I'm still
[ __ ] dizzy okay all right this
[ __ ] story was posted on reddit so
this thing was this photo was attached
to it and I will read it in a second
what it looks like this and it says at
the top 30-day notice of eviction of
bedroom 60-day notice of eviction of
current residency this is a 30-day
eviction notice effective 8th day of
June 2019 but this was just posted seven
days ago that's why it's relevant now of
separate room located in the basement of
the address you will have access to the
spare couch in the current play room and
you will have access to the master suite
bathroom for hygiene use once a day and
the half bathroom located by the kitchen
throughout the evening you have three
days to clean out your current room with
items you want now want to save for
later and stuff you want to get rid of
you are not to go downstairs to affirm a
permit aforementioned bedroom or
upstairs at any time without prior
permission once the eviction takes place
you are not allowed to harm yourself in
any way or this contract is voided and
you will be escorted from the property
permanently you will are to treat all
members of the current household with
respect in a non-threatening manner at
any time if a threat / harm is received
from you to a family member of the
current household this contract will be
voided and you will be escorted from the
property permanently you must
consistently be seeking employment by
leaving the property starting at 9:00
a.m. until 10:00 p.m. daily unless
otherwise communicated by a parent
due to the celebration of the Sabbath
you will have a free day every Saturday
starting at 6:00 p.m. on Friday to 6:00
p.m. on Saturday no [ __ ] your religion
and then the last part is you have 60
days to save enough money to move into
your own place after 60 days you must
show why you cannot move out or you will
be evicted from the property and it's
signed by 1 2 3 4 people including his
minor sisters either Jewish or
seventh-day if I'm moving out I'm going
to the Church of Satan and registering
immediately and I'm making sure that I
take Instagram photos of it so that my
mother can see it so this kid is she
knows she pushed me into the Church of
st. and tagged all of her mom's friends
exactly so they're either that kids
either suicidal or violent toward like
the family or neither and their parents
are [ __ ] dramatic as hell they can be
handing this to a kid looks like Haley
Joel Osment like when he wasn't and so
they're afraid of their of the
repercussions of what they're doing
because they feel like it's shady so
then they don't want the kid to react
into such a violent loss so it turns out
that this this kid so the original
poster ended up giving more information
after there were a lot of questions and
said the stepdad also made him sleep
outside when he came home at 10 p.m. /
what the contract stated oh by the way
the original thing says the headline
says my parents took in their neighbours
18 year old kid parentheses still in the
eleventh grade who was getting kicked
out because his stepdad stepdad didn't
want another male adult in the house
this Cantus is the contract his parents
made him sign the witness as his sister
who's still a minor so then the other
information here is that he says he has
four sisters one of them is a
one-year-old then kicking out then
kicking him out is the mentality of
you're 18 you can live on your own and
that they can't afford to feed him him
being a male adult in a house with
mostly women was another excuse for
their shitty behavior why cuz they guy
wanted to [ __ ] all the women in there
well they're his stepsisters so
obviously have you watched porn lately
yeah I have yeah I know that what you're
into the the step stepbrother thing well
yeah it's just all poured all of it is
some kind of incest just got a block out
the title just see it has two people
[ __ ] it's half sisters so this this
person's assuming different mothers he's
an honest good kid he's lived with my
parents and siblings for almost two
months now and he has always been
respectful and helpful around the house
my mom went to his school to change his
address to hers and ask how he has how
he is as a student and was told that he
has never gotten into trouble so
self-harm part of the contract is
because earlier in the year he attempted
suicide from his family situation he
last spoke to his father a few weeks ago
and they genuinely do not care what he's
doing now that the first response was
what the [ __ ] do you want when my own
father who was speaking to his father
handed the phone to him they don't call
texts and money or anything they told my
father that if he wants to come back
home then to deposit him in front of
their mailbox he never did anything
wrong to receive treatment like this his
mom called my mom and fabricated a lie
by saying he sexually assaulted someone
on his bus but during that time my mom
had been taking him to school and
picking him up personally and questioned
how this was possible his mom had
nothing to say to verify my mom
confirmed with the school that he didn't
sexually assault anyone huh but you know
what's cool though this family keeps the
Sabbath holy yes that's what's important
we're very religious it's like you know
what but they're good Christians though
it's nice when it comes to that or if
they're Jewish or whatever they are you
know when it's time it's time and they
worship their God through do you think
the Jewish Ribera against the contract
was Sabbath I think that's what the
Sabbath is right
well Venice to date but typically yeah
any Saturday religions yeah so this was
going around like damn that's [ __ ] up
how do they just treat their kid like
this there's a lot of [ __ ] in the world
I feel like that happens all the
though I feel like like while you're
saying this I'm like this is kind of
like I just feels like it happens on a
regular no like like that not to me no I
love the whole like you're not another
self-harm man we took care of that
didn't we yeah I know is it in the
contract by the way don't hurt yourself
while you're living in this house
specifically now it's while you are
living all my property you don't kill
yourself okay all right no illegal acts
by the way suicide is illegal okay a
bunch of [ __ ] idiots these people and
they think they're so smart with all his
[ __ ] legal language sounding [ __ ]
like here here - here - for therefore
like [ __ ] a we get it yeah so now the
original poster was also mentioning that
now he's his parents are teaching him
how to drive and that she lives in a big
city and that she was gonna go visit her
family and her new brother so now like
they've kind of adopted biscuit see what
what was funny about this is it doesn't
like doesn't sound there was any warning
like hey we gained you're moving out or
it's just like BAM like or they would
have prepared I'm like teaching them how
to [ __ ] Drive like there's none of
that I've heard that this happens a lot
were like the mom gets with the new man
he comes in he doesn't like the current
conditions and he just changes it damn
and and then the kids get the [ __ ] end
of it but then sometimes the mom does it
for survival or like you know it's not
because yeah she's just stuck in the
middle and there's just all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] that goes down like that
yeah which is common but it's always
brushed under the rug you know no one
really knows that that's happening to
your neighbor or whatever
why do stepdads always like have a beer
in their hand and yelling about
something mall smoking a cigarette
though what's with that and a mustard
stain on the tank top yeah what's with
that what be with that that could have
been me yeah the stereotype what do you
mean could have been you could still be
me I mean I might be a step that one day
I'm still young veteran I can still do
it
I came in a lot of people it could have
been hands only
I could have you dated a girl ahead
again no you do these talk my fans know
lots of speaking offends [ __ ] how am I
gonna how are we ever gonna [ __ ] unless
you subscribe to just my news right
that's become a fan of just kidding
yes and subscribe to the channel don't
you want me as your step dad you can go
not your step dad your step husband and
step that to your children it's almost
like entering the sweepstakes when you
subscribe to just kidding it's like
entering the sweepstakes for this guy
yeah Joe comes with it mhm everyone's
gonna unsubscribe now oh sorry sorry
sorry please don't
[Music]